Faunus dark brave man terrible judgment attacking
him was stupid Lannister's don't act like fools
you spend too much time worrying about what other
people think of you I could care less what anyone
thinks of me you know that's what you want people
to think of you so the lion does concern himself
with the opinions that's not an opinion it's
a fact you've served as a glorified bodyguard
for two kings what a madman the other a drunk
the rumors of your demise were unfounded sorry
to disappoint you your brother would never have
submitted to capture so meekly I always thought
you were a stunted fool oh one more thing you
will not take that [__] to court you brought
a [__] into my bed it wasn't your bed at the
time you chose to spend your days as you always
have bedding harlots and drinking with thieves
you want Casterly Rock it is mine by right and
I would let myself be consumed by maggots before
mocking the family name and making you heir to
Casterly Rock why why you ask that you are an
ill-made spiteful little creature full of envy
lust and low cunning but neither God's nor men
will ever compel me to let you turn Casterly Rock
into your whorehouse well if I would start a war
for that lecherous little stump Margaery has her
claws in Joffrey she knows how to manipulate him
good I wish you knew how to manipulate him I don't
distrust you because you're a woman I distrust you
because you're not as smart as you think you are
Sansa Stark is a finer reward than you could ever
dare hope for and it is past time you were Wed I
was Wed don't you remember only two well they all
marry ser loras they're still fertile you need to
marry again and breed I am Queen Regent not some
broodmare my daughter you will do as I command
and you will marry Loras Tyrell well they don't
make me do it again please not another word my
children you disgraced the Lannister name for far
too long you can joke you can engage in juvenile
attempts to make your father uncomfortable but
you will do your duty I am the king any man who
must say I am the king is no true king now make
sure you understand that when I won your war for
you perhaps that puts family first will always
defeat the house that puts the whims and wishes
of its sons and daughters first regardless of his
own selfish desires dessert amuse you know it's a
very good lesson when have you ever done something
that wasn't in your interest but solely for the
benefit of the family the day that you were born
but my answers still no I don't want Casterly Rock
I don't have wife I don't have children what do
you want seven would be nice for 40 years I've
tried to teach you they haven't learned by now you
never will go if serving as a glorified bodyguard
is the sum of your ambition go serve your brother
was not a wise King your brother was not a good
king if he had been properly to still be alive
always hated Tyrion he killed his king as did
I and if you run cold is it in hearing another
one of your smug stories about the time you won
this isn't going to be one of those times do
you think you'll be the first person dragged
into a Sept to be married against her will when
you marched into the throne room to tell me we
won the Battle of Blackwater do you remember your
son man I am your son I have always been your son